oh
[Musique]
c'est l'esprit de noël les paras potes
et oui c'est moi c'est sûr si si
regardez alors les parapentes est-ce que
vous avez été sages cette année
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo le
concept est très simple toute l'année on
s'est demandé si vous étiez des merdes
là on va se demander l' inverse on va se
demander si vous avez été assez sage
pour recevoir des cadeaux à noël
pourquoi cette vidéo va tout simplement
parce que cette année pour noël j'ai le
coc vide
merci merci pour le coup j'ai pas pu
aller à noël et après je me suis dit non
mais ça ça n'arrivera pas si je suis le
père noël
donc je suis devenu le père noël le
temps d'une vidéo et je vais vous rincer
je vous ai demandé sur instagram de
m'envoyer votre lettre du père noël à
dire tout ça au passage je voulais me
faire un cadeau de noël vous êtes 94000
là sur instagram et moi je me suis dit
il ya quelques mois je m'étais
dit cette année franchement il ya moyen
je passe les 100000 on est à quelques
jours de la fin de l'année je suis pas à
100 milles je sais pas combien vous êtes
de milliers regardez cette vidéo mais on
peut passer aux 100000 voilà si vous
voulez me faire plaisir on passe ce cap
cette année ce sera incroyable
maintenant tu rêves de tergiversions il
est temps d'attaquer les lettres de noël
et la douche nu et de
la neige étant son manteau blanc
[Musique]
cher père noël je m'appelle eric j'ai 16
ans et je suis en terminale mais dis
donc tu a sauté quelques classes eric je
crois que j'ai été sage cette année par
exemple après avoir voulu sortir avec
une fille avec qui ça n'a plus aboutie
et fait le choix d'aller de l'avant
aujourd'hui on est de très bons amis
c'est bien tu veux bien chez rita
relation de plus j'ai bien travaillé
jeudi 17 au bac de français écrit et
oral à je suis rentrée au conservatoire
de versailles et ma ceinture noire de
judo me dis donc qu'est l'enfant
accompli j'ai également fait des
concessions de plaisir personnel pour
tenir mes engagements en restant sur un
projet qui ne plaisait pas claude que de
faire un marathon james bond au grand
rex rigole pas c'est hyper dur mais je
crois que c'était un choix responsable
effectivement je pense que c'était un
choix responsable je connais ce genre de
dilemme j'ai toujours essayé de faire le
bon choix parmi trois sages amérique
j'aime les sacrifices le père noël va te
récompenser aussi j'ai essayé de montrer
plus d'affection pour mes proches c'est
bien eric je fais de belles surprises
pour mes meilleurs amis et même composer
des morceaux pour mes proches on aurait
aimé entendre un morceau pour finir cet
été j'ai aidé une vieille dame a porté
ses courses rentrer dans l'eau et
l'avait ses chaussures planned plein de
sable à la plage cercle rentrer dans
l'eau ça que tu l'a accompagné genre
vous accompagnez genre dans la mer un
plaisir surtout les chaussures
puis dis donc tu t'es investi quand même
alors j'ai aussi des plus mauvais moment
mais à part une fois où j'ai eu un peu
trahi la confiance de mes parents et mes
grands-parents en faisant du bruit à
l'appartement que mes grands-parents
m'avait gentiment confié je n'ai
vraiment pas fait de bêtise
effectivement si c'est ça ta pires
bêtises ces seuils toutes ces histoires
n'ont rien à voir les unes avec les
autres mais ça montre que je crois que
j'ai été sage en cette année 2010 21
ainsi je te demande à toi et aux lutins
l'un de ces objets tout ce ne serait pas
raisonnable un iphone à partir du 10 ça
j'apprécie un on n'est pas forcément sur
le dernier modèle et ça c'est chouette
cette figurine de candale à elle est
incroyable elle est incroyable elle est
incroyable on dirait moi un peu wright
bosphorus poignée master vintage qu'est
ce que c'est que cette chose on sait que
c'est un vélo mais pas du tout on
appelle ça une par balle c'est ça mais
c'est juste une ça coûte 500 balles
juste une allée en fait quand tu disais
que tu faisais du bruit chez ses
grands-parents là tu faisais pas
semblant en fait elle mais ça coûte cher
ces trucs là en tout cas tu es le boss
de régaler chaque année merci le sens
écoute
[Musique]
eric j'ai été touché par ta lettre
je t'offre la figurine de gandalf ainsi
que le grind bosphorus tout animateur
vintage ça me fait plaisir régal toi
mon cher père noël j'ai voulu commencer
cette lettre avec une blague sur le pôle
nord ce n'est après dix minutes je dois
me rendre à l'évidence que c'est un
échec cuisant donc je vais clairement
m'arrêter là rien que pour ça je verrai
un cadeau non non si j'ai bien compris
d'après les codes je suis d'abord 107e
donné mon nom et mon âge alors très bien
je m'appelle gwenaëlle me répète mais
rien que pour ça je leur est un cadeau
non n'ont toujours pas et j'ai 22 ans je
n'aurais jamais la prétention de te
demander une montagne de cadeaux
seulement une ou deux bricoles mais en
quel honneur me demandera tu es bien je
vais te dire cette année je suis fier de
moi et ça c'est un truc de dingue en
effet j'ai toujours été une petite fille
et ensuite une ado exemplaire super sage
et malgré tout je n'ai jamais reçu
d'iphone pour noël ça craint n'ont pu
non plus jamais de reçus d'iphone à noël
du coup cette année je me suis dit que
visiblement il manquait quelque chose
alors je n'ai pas fait les choses à
moitié je suis parti étudier quatre mois
en espagne tout seul sans personne genre
vraiment personne et ça pour moi c'est
complètement locaux et oui je suis un
peu bilingue maintenant moi pas du tout
donc je ne sais pas ce que ça veut dire
locaux mais j'imagine que c'est quelque
chose de positif
cyrus est beau gosse car la solitude
c'est pas vraiment ce que je préfère
j'ai toujours eu l'habitude d'être très
bien entouré de ne jamais passé
énormément de temps seul ya bien de la
chance et ces derniers mois j'ai
découvert ce que ça faisait de rester
seul en ma compagnie d'aller lire au
parc seul de regarder un film seul de
manger au resto seul vraiment j'insiste
parce que c'est un exploit effectivement
c'est quelque chose de difficile et en
vrai de vrai c'est pas mal du tout c'est
pas mal du tout je veux permettre de
nuancer que par le propos grenelle c'est
pas mal du tout lorsqu'on a le x en
vérité m'adresse à tous les gens qui
sont seuls et qui le subissent après il
faut être honnête je me suis très vite
fait des amis mais cela ne va pas
empêcher d'apprécier la solitude ce dont
j'étais incapable tout cela m'amène au
fait que pure et je suis fier de moi et
ça ça ne m'est pas arrivé très souvent
je vous ai partir seul dans une ville
que je ne connaissais pas j'ai suivi des
cours dans une langue qui n'est pas ma
langue maternelle j'ai rencontré des tas
de gens et je me suis aussi un peu
rencontre et moi même au final et ça
c'est beau alors désolé père noël je
n'ai pas fait spécialement de bonnes
actions ou en tout cas aucune qui ne
vaille la peine de mentionner mais je
pense que cette année au delà d'être
sage j'ai accompli quelque chose en plus
ça crée un peu bad ass merci alors que
le temps de me lire et merci de me gâter
peut être aucune obligation bien sûr
guen une par rapport à si avec tout ça
ce serait bête beaulieu ma liste de
cadeaux à un iphone 13 du coup on doit
bien ça pour compenser toutes les neiges
derrière reçus dont mehdi dont on est où
là et vous c'est quoi ça le manuscrit le
nam bô variées aux éditions saint père
ou au choix celui de l'équipe des
chevaux et voilà je suis partagé là
parce que c'est chose dont on est fier
parce que je pensais que tu as été sage
là on parle d'avoir été sage pour moi
même si je suis fier de toi bravo
félicitations c'est pas évident de faire
ce que tu as fait bravo même chose que
d'être sage malheureusement je ne pense
pas à s'offrir un cadeau thalys mais il
y est le sponsor de cette vidéo conflit
kambly une plateforme qui permet de
prendre des cours d'anglais avec des
vrais anglophone travailler son oral
j'en reparlerai à la fin de la vidéo
mais kambly m'a dit que pour ceux et
celles qui n'auraient pas de cadeau il
offrait un abonnement gratuit je t'offre
donc un abonnement kambly ne me remercie
par wayne tu sembles être quelqu'un de
formidable et vous envoie race très fort
ça c'est ce que tu m'as dit que je
devais un iphone matthaus bonjour daddy
noël morgan 25 ans totalement saoul
qu'ovide pour les fêtes de fin d'année
on est ensemble comme on dit il est
difficile pour moi d'évaluer ce qu'il
faut dire mérité un cadeau mais
honnêtement je suis un stade de ma vie
où j'ai fait tout ce qu'il fallait pour
que ça aille et rien ne va
morgane ça ça nous font le coeur à tous
j'ai commencé 2021 seul sur son live sur
twitter à l'époque je travaille pour des
mecs qui se foutait de moi je ne gagne
rien et mon dur travail n'était jamais
reconnu mais j'ai eu la force de partir
j'ai trouvé un autre travail dans une
entreprise superbe avec un boss un peu
toxiques mais je commence à avoir
l'habitude c'est triste quand même là
avec mon nouvel emploi j'ai pu quitter
mon 13 mètres carrés à moi aussi j'avais
un très bon début d'une nouvelle vie
joie bonheur j'ai vécu trois mois avec
seulement un matelas sur le sol un lave
vaisselle j'arrive à le meublé petit à
petit mais mon addiction aux plantes
prend tout mon budget sacré morgan on en
a des points communs en vrai je sais pas
vraiment ce que je raconte je suis
fatigué des efforts que j'ai faits sans
relâche pendant toute cette année qui de
base ce n'est comme la meilleure année
de ma vie pour plein de raisons mais qui
au final reste ultra nul je reste seule
mais mieux entourer jamais et je crois
que j'ai pris cette lettre au papa noël
pour un moyen de parler un peu de ce que
je ressens peut-être que ça suffira pour
tu estimes que j'ai mérité un cadeau de
noël j'ai été sage je fais tous les
jours du bien autour de moi j'essaie
d'être un soleil rayonnant même quand je
suis grise à l'intérieur geof que paix
amour j'ai hâte de le ressentir en mots
waouh touchant cette morgan la voici ma
liste des choses que je ne peux pas
m'offrir mais qui me ferait très plaisir
un lit coffre ikea parce que dormir par
terre c'est cool mais prendre de la
hauteur c'est agréable aussi c'est
intéressant c'est le mâle main figurent
trois que je l'avais aussi voilà je
l'avais acheté lorsque je vivais avec
mon ex très pratique 1 le côté coffre où
il rangé des choses on apprécie bien sûr
que papa noël te l'offre le tapis de mes
rêves j'ai des frissons rien que
d'imaginer mais peut-on frôlé sa douceur
ultime en 6 par huit c'est précis il est
magnifique très bon ah oui quand même
c'est
d'accord à leur écoute sinon un grand
miroir n'importe lequel et des jolies
plantes ah oui je choisis d'accord je
pensais que tout et que je t'offre tout
ça à la fois mais morgane ta lettre m'a
vraiment touché et tu auras à la fois le
lit et le tapis qui va avec morgane je
te souhaite un excellent noël et
j'espère que 2022
sera plus ensoleillé que 2021 suite
pardon je corrige mal est trop attention
rebondissements tu as déjà gagné les
cadeaux cette année je mérite un cadeau
parce que j'ai fait du mieux que j'ai pu
décocher sikasso sur ma taux de l'is de
2021 de visiter deux capitales d'europe
je gagne enfin de correctement ma vie
j'ai un vrai appartement je suis entouré
de belles personnes saines et aimant je
me suis prouvé que la vie pouvait être
savoureuse qu'on y mettait du sien j'ai
tout donné j'ai reçu plein de choses une
jolie base table pour toutes les choses
que je veux développer maintenant je
trouvais mal être trop triste j'ai
pleuré un coup puis j'ai décidé que ce
qui valait le mieux est de regarder ce
qu'on avait accompli et tout ce que je
t'ai écrit là je n'aurais jamais été
capable de l'accomplir en 2020 alors
voilà je suis fier de moi fier de tout
ce qui se bagarrent pour voir ce qu'ils
veulent plein d'amour sur vous keith
lorca écoute morgan fait aussi gagner le
miroir et les plantes aller ça suffit ça
suffit morgan
bonjour papa noël je me présente
rapidement je m'appelle simon jeune
garçon de 24 ans mesurant 1 mètre 94
cette année je pense avoir été un être
humain très sage cette année j'ai fait
qu'une seule betis c'est osé de
commencer son mail directement par la
bêtise un jour d'énervement à cause d'un
burnout psychologique j'ai cassé ma
table d'un coup de pied elle a
maintenant un grand et rien d'autre
n'est cassé ensuite voulu pendant
quelques jours puis j'ai médité pour
éviter de réitérer ce genre d'épisode
bravo mon bon ciment sinon j'ai passé il
fait très chaud là il fait très chaud
enlever ça
ça vous dérange
sinon j'ai passé mon année être sinon
simon tu veux dire ah ah yes ok sinon
j'ai passé mon année à travailler
durement mon activité
d'auto-entrepreneur en tant que designer
graphique j'ai développé un site
internet avec une page instagram et tout
ce qui s'accompagne au tour côté amour
je suis avec ma copine depuis cinq ans
et ça continue encore avec toujours plus
d'impôts mais c'est beau ça à 24 ans
j'ai aussi plus tradition donc s'était
généralisé irritation ainsi que
l'acceptation des choses qui m'entourent
me permettent aujourd'hui d'être moins
stressé au quotidien j'essaie toujours
d'être au quotidien une meilleure
personne que la veille c'est beau c'est
une belle devise ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui je pense avoir passé mon
année le plus sagement possible afin de
recevoir un cadeau de ta part aussi je
suis allé offrir pour rencontrer sur
east north et ça s'est super bien passé
quelle personne incroyable
j'espère que j'ai été assez sage et que
la table cassez ne causera pas de tort
voilà tout ce jour à ma liste de noël
juste vivre de graphisme de pyramide
édition à n'importe lequel pour je
t'enverrai peut-être à mai pour savoir
lequel tu veux écouteurs bluetooth jabra
élite 65,3 en full sleep chioukh gu10
coloré ipad d'apple peinent si le calme
toi calme toi ok tu attends mais de
soleil comme vélo ni un voyage aller
retour à tokyo ma copine tu te calmes tu
te détends mario party superstar sur
switch écoute
simon je t'offre les trois premiers que
tu as l'air personne très sympathique
j'avoue il n'y a pas eu le truc
exceptionnel qui t'aurait valu le voyage
aller-retour à tokyo peut-être l'année
prochaine je rappelle quand même que tu
as cassé une table en fin de droit
d'enlever les ampoules
j'enlève la barre aulas que ça commence
à être
bonjour papa north je suis un jeune
homme de 17 ans et j'ai été sage cette
année et que je te leproux d'asie frérot
est le mec fait ma réponse est déjà je
n'ai jamais le coc vite de ma vie moi un
wôrô
fera pas de cadeau qu'on va continuer
cette lettre mais tu auras mada de plus
j'ai passé les épreuves du bac de
français cette année j'en suis sorti
avec un 17 sur 20 à l'oral et 18 sur 20
à l'écrit franchement bg non je la bête
un petit peu je trouve malheureusement
tout n'a pas été rose puisque le 13
novembre en 2021 j'ai été exclu de mon
match de rugby après m'être dénoncé
comme coupable lors d'une bagarre
générale mais je me suis excusé auprès
de l' arbitre cela puisse l'honnêteté
que j'ai eue pour me dénoncer ont fait
que je n'ai pas été suspendus longtemps
ok donc pas de déclencher une bagarre
générale du coup papa nord si tu trouves
que j'étais sympa cette année mais à
quel moment en fait soit il possible tu
m'envoies le top 100 de one piece en
édition collector ou l'amour de ma meuf
entre temps une belle fin d'année avait
eu 2020 de faire l'amour de ta meuf j'en
suis vraiment je te souhaite que son
offre est le top 100 de one piece non
mon gars non mais kick j'aurais bien
aimé donner quelque chose mais will ou
est ce que tu as été sage même dans ton
mail tu balances des tacles non je ne
peux que d'offrir un abonnement camby et
encore et encore bonjour père noël je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi je mérite
un cadeau j'ai mon brevet avec mention
très bien et ouais déjà oui sans triche
et une médaille aussi j'ai eu mon code
j'ai réussi dans la crypte monnaie c'est
faux j'ai 15 ans papa noël et en plus
j'ai contribué au sacre de max
verstappen en f1 j'étais dans mon canapé
de plus ge élève des poules au crabe
c'est pourquoi je voudrais des amis un
volant pour pleinement
des baskets air force 1 tu connais
blanche de préférence oui je suis route
à 42,5 si jamais un maillot de sms
floqué kouyaté oui je kiffe le fc metz
juge pas écoute j'ai très peu d'éléments
qui montrent que tu as été sage à part
le fait que tu es passé ton brevet sans
tricher ce qui pourrait quand même la
base n'est ce pas vécu le précise et
presque inquiétant de plus tu étais
juste sur ton canapé pendant que verse
la peine à gagner
quel est ton implication je ne ferai
donc pas de cadeaux cette année je suis
désolé par contre quand bhl it offre un
abonnement gratuit on va parler anglais
et ça c'est quand même j'aurais clash
pour noël lorsque c'est le titre du mail
encore une fois bonjour papa noël north
bonjour on écrit en sommeil le titre que
j'aime il me rappelle un vieux disque de
la guerre qui était à mon père déjà
merci pour ça
je vais j'y prise trop tard donc pas
dissertation sur pourquoi j'ai pas été
hiver sergent nul l'intérêt pas de liste
de cadeaux
juste merci à toi tes vidéos c'est un
peu à chaque fois comme des cadeaux pour
nous une vieille mamie 39 ans oh là là
c'est trop touchant c'est pas de cadeaux
effectivement mais trop touchant trop
mignon je prends quand même un
abonnement pour kambly si jamais vous
voulez vous mettre à l'anglais quoi on
salue cyrus je m'appelle pipe
tel prénom de merde je suis une fille
j'ai 21 ans je ne pensais pas vraiment
écrire une lettre un jour et pourtant
j'ai vu ta story et je me suis pas tout
de suite senti concerné et puis j'ai
commencé à réfléchir à ce que je
souhaitais vraiment pour noël et puis je
n'ai pas trouvé je pense mériter un
cadeau j'ai réussi ma licence y accéder
au masters que je souhaitais j'ai gardé
près de moi les gens qui m'était cher je
fais du sport je suivais gagnent et je
fais toujours un bisou un monde où tout
avant de dormir je ne sais pas du tout
si ça c'est une bonne raison en plus de
ça je suis étudiante et donc par
définition je suis pas blindé droutsas
et là tu me fous la possibilité de
choisir un cadeau de ouf mais pourquoi
vous pensez que pourquoi vous mettez
tous des cadeaux de ouf c'est quoi ces
cadeaux de ouf la personne mais des
cadeaux à moins de 500 balles et donc la
team offre la possibilité de choisir un
cadeau de ouf et je vais te répondre que
je veux un puzzle
n'est pas la même réponse que mes
parents c'est sûr ne pas vouloir quelque
chose de ton âge que je skie très utile
des vêtements même de l'argent si tu
veux non je veux un puzzle
j'ai bien cherché et rien ne me ferait
plus plaisir il permet de m'évader de me
retrouver de pensée de considérer le
temps qui passe et vu la paire de merde
que l'on dit c'est le meilleur remède
possible merci d'avoir questionner mais
réel souhait pour ce noël bonne vidéo
[Musique]
c'est quoi je t'offre 3 puzzle 3 puzzle
et un abonnement compris à samaa trop
toucher 1
salut père noël salue cette année je
crois que j'ai pas été super sage
l'honnêteté on apprécie après deux ans
de relation j'ai quitté mon copain puis
j'ai décidé de profiter de la vie
notamment de la vie étudiante j'ai 20
ans et je suis dans une grande école en
haïti c'est que cette année j'ai
rencontré un mec avec qui je me suis pas
bien entendu on est rapidement devenus
proches jusqu'à se voir et couché
ensemble régulièrement cependant plus le
temps avance et plus on développe en
somme une relation mais de l'autre côté
j'ai toujours envie de m'amuser de
manière plus légère sauf qu'avec ce mec
ça lui fait mal que je fasse ça il me le
disait pas au début puis évidemment il
ya des sentiments qui sont mêlé à ça je
n'aurais pas dire à quel moment sûrement
un peu des plus débat on en a beaucoup
parlé mais pour autant j'ai continué à
lui mentir pendant des mois sur le fait
que je couchais régulièrement avec un
autre gars là on n'est pas sûrs et de
vous des mères mais ça aurait sa place
voilà maintenant il sait tout ça et pour
2022 j'essaierai d'aspirer à plus
d'honnêteté pas seulement vers ces deux
personnes bon malizé de noël fait pas
rêver mais j'aimerais bien des bouquins
majoritairement tu arrives et n'avoir
par contre tu n'auras rien et au dos
mais bien essayé bien essayé salut cyrus
noël
pourquoi pas je m'appelle martin j'ai 14
ans à roubaix au moment où j'écris et
peut-être 15 moment où tu lis ce message
clair c'est le 28 décembre donc toujours
je t'écris aujourd'hui vous êtes des
jeunes il ya des gens aussi jeune qui
regarde l'historique je t'écris
aujourd'hui car j'ai été un gentil en
france année je voudrais d'abord
t'écrire un résumé de mon année très
chargée j'ai commencé en colombie après
à madagascar a fini en france vas-y tu
as déjà eu des cadeaux et finit en
france et tout pour l'expatriation pas
de voyages vacances
oui mes mots ah les vacances mais quand
même qui fait mais finalement c'est pas
drôle donc je vais écrire autre chose
depuis presque toujours je suis phobique
d aiguille de seringue et autres trucs
qui rentre dans la peau pour la faire
courte j'ai le schéma vaccinal complet
festation après j'ai eu d'excellentes
notes pendant le premier trimestre et le
début du deuxième voilà sinon pour le
cadeau j'aimerais une table de bureau en
noyer de ikea mais c'est super chiant
envoyé aucune idée de comment faire mais
j'aimerais beaucoup ça vu que je
déménage pour mon nouveau bureau il a
mis ses moyennes hawass in-stat c'est
une star
19 50 sa moyenne générale à l'asie on va
t'offrir ta table
moi je suis papa noël je suis je suis
papa noël font dire je suis clairement
un papa noël méritocratie quoi s'ils
vont avoir un bulletin scolaire a eu des
bonnes notes à l'aide qu on va te
l'envoyer je sais pas comment mais on va
se débrouiller
salut cyrus et kate papa noël d'union
off je m'appelle lola j'ai 23 ans et
pour te prouver que j'ai été sage tout
au long de l'année 2021 je vais te
raconter une seule anecdote un peu
longue qui je l'espère te permettra de
constater ma sagesse lola la tracking go
un jour en allant à la salle de sports
j'habite au centre ville de metz et je
me rends donc à pied puisqu'elle se
situe route plein ville en pleine ville
pardon je me fais arrêter par un
bénévole d'une association qui
recherchent à récolter des financements
avant toute chose le mec est
physiquement incroyable m'explique
brièvement contre quoi luttent
l'association le mec est hyper
charismatique il ponctue son explication
de blague et je rigole bêtement de a à z
c'est sûr ce n'est pas moi mais je lui
dis que je suis encore étudiante et je
n'ai pas les moyens de donner pour le
moment des au papa noël du nord tu m'a
rattrapé après normalement mais ce
qu'ils défendent intéressés j'aimerais
bien trouver l'assaut sur les réseaux in
older facebook instagram et rajoute on a
même un conte only fans ce à quoi je
rigole encore bien niaisement on se
salue et je me dis qu'il faut que je le
trouve sur les ce soir je parcours les
abonnés des comptes qui m'a étonné mais
n'ayant aucune info sur lui c'est
mission impossible dégoûté mais tant pis
deux jours plus tard je retourne en
ville et en route pour rentrer chez moi
je me fais à nouveau arrêté par un autre
membre de l'association cette fois je ne
peux évidemment toujours pas donné mais
le feeling passe trop bien et on discute
pendant une quinzaine de minutes super
cool mais dégoûté de ne pas m'être fait
arrêter par le mec de la dernière fois
je continue ma route et là je le vois au
loin il discute avec d'autres passants
là je me dis qu'il faut que j'y aille je
me laisse pas le choix culotté je fais
semblant d'attendre quelqu'un devant un
magasin je sais ce qu'il soit seul but
je fonce vers lui l'air de rien un peu
nonchalante et sans me reconnaître
hilmar est à nouveau prêt à faire son
speech hymne salué sans laisser le temps
de lui répondre r vous savez il ya deux
jours j'ai essayé de chercher son
premier fan mais j'ai pas trouvé au mais
c'est toi la fille devant la salle je me
souviens est comme ça tape à très bon
compte j'ai bien cherché mais sans ton
prénom c'était compliqué avec mon numéro
sera peut-être plus facile
il donne alors son numéro et me dit de
lui écrire je m'en vais dans ma tête
c'est dingue et rentrer chez moi on
discute il vient pas d'ici et il en
mission pour l'association il fait un
peu le tour de france il part de metz
dans dix jours on se dit qu on ira boire
un verre le week end elle limite tant
mieux tant mieux comme ça tac petite
amourette il ya une date de fin is it le
croiser en ville la semaine on march
côte à côte sans se rendre compte tout
de suite on parle quelques instants
comme ça sans s'en rendre compte tout de
suite on part quelques instants avant de
se séparer nos chemins bien le week end
je le rejoindrai anbar il y avait toute
l'équipe de bénévoles commencent à lui
avec toute l'équipe de bénévoles est on
voulait juan toile là où l'un des hits
la revoit alors celui avec qui j'ai
parlé pendant 15 minutes on passe la
soirée tous ensemble c ok quand le bars
ferment on va en boîte dans la boîte
ferme on se retrouve tous dans le r vis
à vis des deux mecs qui m'ont arrêté
d'en discuter on boit et c'est trop cool
comme ça vous êtes toujours pas que deux
tout le monde rentre chez soi sauf moi
qui passe la nuit avec celui qu'on
appellera thomas on passe le week end
ensemble comme si on se connaissait
depuis je ne sais combien de temps c'est
ouf à
présent je vois toujours pas le rapport
avec ton cadeau de noël mais on va
continuer on soit pas trop la semaine
mais on se dit que ce week-end leur
dernier week end à metz au sort et en
profite je me réveille mercredi j'ai
reçu un message de thomas ils ont fait
la fête dans leurs habits nba hier soir
et sont fait virer en pleine nuit qui
sont donc tous les deux à la rue pour
les quatre jours qu'il en reste ici pas
très responsable thomas vient le mou qui
j'espère te fera noter mon prénom dans
la colonne sage je propose de les
héberger chez moi ou vous si mon père
d'apprendre que j'héberge deux inconnus
chez moi et mes gorge il m'accroche
pardon il écorche il m'a accroché au
plafond atteint ces passages tu voulais
juste passer la nuit avec excusez moi je
pense qu'il ya eu une mésentente sur ce
qu'est être sage c'est parce c'est pas
du tout ça ça je sais tu que sage
s'arrêter au contraire de suivre le
conseil de ton père je rappelle à ce
moment de l'histoire que le mec me plaît
puissance 1000 bah oui c'est pour ça
qu'il ya rien de sage dans le fait de
lui proposer de revenir chez toi et que
j'ai l'impression d'être dans un film
pass 4 jours ensemble on a pas enfin il
travaille et je vais en cours et le soir
on se retrouve on écoute de la musique
en parlant garder film c'est de la bombe
cas j'avoue salaire de la bombe le
dernier soir on sort à nouveau avec
toute l'équipe mais tout le monde
fatigue assez vite sauf thomas et moi à
ce que zuma d'énergie pour faire parler
de choses on doit retourner en boîte il
y avait oublié sa chemise à la fois
comment il fait pour oublier une chemise
en boîte nivelles juste pour la chemise
mais une fois dans la boîte on est
tellement bien qu'on y reste ou danse en
plein milieu comme si la boîte vous
appartenez comme si avec que nous encore
il faut jouer dans un film on rentre
lendemain matin ils sont
on se réveille je les accompagne à la
gare devant il ya toute l'équipe énorme
câlin tout surtout aux deux garçons qui
ont passé la semaine chez moi donc
thomas qui me prend à part pour me
remercier en disant à quel point je suis
génial je m'en vais sans me retourner
pour éviter qu'on coeur ne tombe par
terre impossible parce qu'en fait il est
maintenu dans la cage thoracique n'est
pas plein d'autres fibres en fait
qui le sait n'est jamais arrivé arrivé
chez moi je reçois un message me disant
on se recroise à un jour franc
depuis je me dis que la vie est belle et
pleine de rencontres inoubliables
et tout ça pour dire que j'ai peut-être
pas fait le don à l'assaut mais je
donnais tout mon coeur en les faisant
venir vivre chez moi et en partageant
ces moments avec voilà va super histoire
se termine là elle est incroyable mais
tu n'aura aucun cadeau aucun désolé
désolé lola désolé tu as l'air
incroyable etc mais il n'y a rien de
sage dans ce que tu vas me raconter ces
packs nous donc je te paie un abonnement
kambly pour apprendre l'anglais et ça
c'est cool aussi comme ça tu lui s'est
passé avec thomas tu sais que tu vivras
avec jack
c'est non négligeable md qu'un un peu
long et chiant titre du mail donc you
bon j'ai la maxi flemme de faire un
paragraphe 2 ou venant gros j'ai été
sage
en vrai pour la vanne sérieuse des
petites idées si tu es un mec marrant en
plus pour la vidéo ces galeries un peu
dans un petit cd ou vinyle sont encore
mieux de nepal dès que feu pnl ou alors
juste quelqu'un que tu kiffes pour que
je découvre et hop tu fais la sélection
en voici rust plus fervents auditeurs du
meilleur podcast c'était pas tom qui a
fait cette élection c'était b d'un cerf
bah non là tu vas rien à voir
à quel nom je suis désolé aucun effort
aucun effort moi je veux bien essayer
des trucs et tout mais aucun effort cher
papa noël du north je m'appelle clémence
j'espère alors que tu m'accordes rata
clémence pour cette lettre
et j'ai 23 ans cette année je pense
avoir été particulièrement sage et je
mérite alors amplement un cadeau ça
c'est moi qui décide tu constateras
qu'en plus d'avoir été un ange cette
année je suis resté modeste déjà j'ai
fait mon stage dans le cadre de mon
master en sciences politiques dans une
association bon d'accord c'est la seule
structure qui met répondu positivement
ok donc mais c'est quand même bien je
n'ai presque pas abuser du télétravail
en restant un pyjama dans mon lit sans
rien faire lors de mes jours en
présentiel j'ai servi le café à mes
collègues sans m'offusquer du rôle de
stage à café que l'on me donnait ça
j'apprécie prendre compte john irish de
stoïciens là-dedans l'apprécient n'est
non plus jamais crié au scandale combat
tutrice reprenait mes idées en réunion
en se vantant qu'elle venait d'elle
saran ou flux gagnent des points
ça par titre mais
en dehors de ça je rentrais tous les
week-ends chez mes parents pour
m'occuper d'eux et absolument pas pour
profiter de mets délicieux et gratuit
fait par ma maman dans le même ordre
d'idée j'appelle également mes
grands-parents toutes les semaines pour
prendre de leurs nouvelles pas de
vanille si je le fais vraiment tu gagne
des points je suis également une soeur
très attentionné toujours là pour lui
répéter que le mec qu'elle fréquente est
un énorme connard quand elle m'appelle
en pleurant pour finalement me tire le
lendemain que c'est l'homme de sa vie
rien des points enfin je suis toujours
la première à me porter volontaire
lorsque l'un des proches a besoin de
quelque chose même dans les situations
imité rapidement qu'on aurait mieux fait
de se taire pour 1 pour finir les
concernant la liste de cadeaux mon
ancien copain lui n'a pas été sage cette
année et a donc décidé de me larguer
comme une merde je souhaiterais alors un
tyson et rap il est temps d'avoir une
chevelure de rêve être sortir de la team
célibataire de manière anticipée
allais-je de l'offre à les autres idées
et parce que je sais que cela ferait
plaisir à mes voisins j'aimerais
beaucoup avoir un clavier numérique
histoire de perfectionner les
compétences au piano que j'apprends
depuis peu on va rester sur le
sèche-cheveux une dernière pour la route
je serais ravi d'avoir un joli tarot
divinatoire histoire de savoir ce que
2022 réserve sûrement pas tarir les
balises sur l'astrologie jambes ferait
même pas sur le tarot merci papa noël du
north pour le temps que tu passeras lien
mal-être j'espère que quelqu'un
penserait également offert un joli
cadeau pour noël c'est vrai ça qui offre
un cadeau au père noël écoute cette
année en pour noël en cadeau de noël je
n'ai rien eu voilà ah si peut-être
franchir les 100 me de charges car votre
plein de bisous clemenceau je t'embrasse
et en même temps mon cadeau c'est vous
c'est une blague à dos et vous mon
cadeau c'est de faire ça mon cadeau
c'est de vous offrir des choses voilà
voilà pas de danse tout d'abord je vais
pour et j'ai dit comme tout d'abord
force et honneur à toi pour combattre ce
satané virus en période festive en
espérant que de nombreuses lettres font
sourire et vêtements bobby sur ton petit
coeur c'est un plaisir alors voilà je
m'appelle camille fraîchement
trentenaire perdu dans un petit bled
dans le sud-ouest de la france en coloc
avec mon chat léon j'adore les ont comme
un chat comme prénom déjà je veux dire
après six ans excusez moi j'ai un chat
dans la gorge dans léon léon
après six ans de relation compliquée
passionnés mais aussi très toxique avec
mon ex qui selon m je me reconstruis
petit à petit je ne savais plus où
j'allais et puis une opportunité s'est
présentée comme une évidence depuis une
semaine je suis l'heureuse propriétaire
en solo une petite maison de village et
tupac qui va mais t'as quel âge à 39
estation festation en effet l'ancien
propriétaire avait le syndrome de
diogène
elle cumulait tout ce qui pouvait être
dont ses excréments une sacrée aventure
c'est horrible ça c'est sûr qu'un acquis
car cette vidéo qui sont confrontés au
syndrome de diogène vous envoie la force
quelles qu'elles soient c'est horrible
c'est un de diogène vous savez ce que
c'est ou pas on diogène philosophe qu'on
ne présente plus il vivait dans son
tonneau vous savez mais le syndrome de
diogène c'est des gens qui vivent là
dedans quoi ils ont besoin d'accumuler
chauzy les entasse c'est terrible j'ai
eu très peur beaucoup réfléchi calculé
il ya énormément de boulot de nettoyage
j'ai la chance d'être bien entouré et
des parts la famille et amis et déjà les
premiers résultats ne font que confirmer
que c'est le bon choix j'ai donc pour
projet d'en faire un airbnb le garage ou
cour intérieure pour ma maison actuelle
oui j'habite collé à son petit change
j'aimerais pouvoir donner l'opportunité
à mes amis d'organiser des week-ends
yoga et auquel tatouage en plus de la
location pour les vacances profitez de
cette cour intérieure enfin j'ai déjà
tout en tête créer et pourquoi pas boire
des mojitos avec toi et bnp de nevers
est tournée 1 entre potes avec mes
copines donc voilà tout ce que je
demande au père noël cette année ce
n'est pas un sac chanel mais simplement
des bons d'achat leroy merlin pour mes
travaux s'il ya de la place dans sa
hotte un week-end chill dans des cabanes
pour décompresser après le taf et les
travaux avec une petit mec ou un
vidéoprojecteur qu'on pourrait mettre
dehors l'été et qui fait des baisers
très cher et même si je ne suis pas
sélectionné tu sera le bienvenu dans
quelques mois pour te ressourcer et
pourquoi pas écrire un autre livre on
n'a qu'à pékin avait un encours les gens
sur youtube n'était pas en cours avant
après aulas tu très joli c'est compliqué
il ya un an c'est très simple 500 balles
de bons d'achat leroy merlin allez allez
construit nous une merveille vas-y vas-y
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu
je remercie évidemment le sponsor de
cette vidéo cas qu'une permettre de vous
rincer comme je lé pu dans une certaine
mesure un dans une certaine mesure ok
pas des vidéos qui font des millions de
vues ok vous mais vous avez si un jour
ça arrive je voudrais un secret mais
vénère pour l'instant je le perds mon
échelle heureusement kambly était là
kambly qu'est ce que c'est qu'on glisse
d'un site qui vous permet d'apprendre et
de pratiquer l'anglais à l'oral avec des
natifs des natifs des gens du pied de
coin du monde un genre qui peuvent être
anglais américains australiens irlandais
avec les dragons cache pas que des
accents différents et vous pouvez
pratiquer avec eux ça peut être en vue
de changer de job ça peut être dans le
but d'être plus à l'aise avec des
clients quand on fait des présentations
ou même préparer certains examens comme
le toefl etc moi j'avoue que ma fonction
était préféré c'est le fait de pouvoir
choisir les accents par exemple si vous
avez un voyage ou un échange à préparer
en irlande voilà où en écosse et des
actions qui peuvent être particulier
dans cette cool d'aller voir les
spécificités et de du coup de discuter
avec un vrai irlandais ou un vrai
écossais pour se faire un petit peu
l'oreille le site est hyper bien fait
tout est hyper clair vous avez même des
discussions pouvaient faire jean
thématiques par exemple sur les séries
télé sur l'éducation bref il ya à boire
et à manger et ça c'est vraiment cool et
en plus vu qu'on va être en 2022 dans
les nouvelles résolutions et c'est le
fait d'apprendre une nouvelle langue le
fait de pratiquer mieux une nouvelle
langue ça rentre parfaitement dans le
très bonnes résolutions donc n'hésitez
pas et en plus vous allez avoir un code
troubles et oui le code c cyrus noël et
vous permet à la fois d'avoir -60% sur
l'abonnement et 15 minutes d'essai
gratuit dans la description je vous mets
un lien pour les 60 % et un lien pour
les 15 minutes mais sachez qu'ils sont
cumulables avec le code cyrus noël je
précise aussi que c'est une profession
qui est limitée dans le temps et elle
est limitée aux 200 premiers inscrits
merci à eux une nouvelle fois d'avoir
soutenu cette vidéo avoir rendu aussi
possible mais pas rapporte c'était un
plaisir cette année est ce que c'est la
dernière vidéo de l'année ce que je fais
un bilan lâche pas de ville en savait
trop peut-être un bilan une future vidéo
bilan je sais pas je sais pas je sais
pas encore je me suis pas encore fait de
programme dans les prochaines semaines
et mois des vidéos à venir mais je vous
embrasse très fort pensée particulière
voilà ce qu'ils ont été seuls sept
années notamment à cause du coc vide
donc dont je fais partie mais aussi à
ceux qui ont été seuls parce que ils
sont seuls en fait qu vide où nous on
pense fort à vous et j'espère que cette
vidéo vous a donné un petit peu de baume
au coeur et vous en rappeler l'esprit de
noël je relève un instant cet
accoutrement je sais aussi que les
gagnants vont m'envoyer une photo de ce
qu'ils ont reçues sur instagram est
comme ça je le partagerai instaurée
comme ça il y aura une petite suite à
cette vidéo parce que vu le timing je
peux pas mettre ces photos là à la fin
de la vidéo comme je l'aurais fait
d'habitude mais voilà vous aurez une
preuve qu'ils ont bien reçu leur cadeau
ciao
[Musique]